the former director of military
operations in the ministry of Defense
Air Marshal Edward Stringer thanks for
being with us so how difficult will this
next phase or possible next phase of the
operation the evacuation be unless there
is a ceasefire
well there's a ceasefire there'll still
be some risk but clearly that would
allow us to make some assumptions
um it will be dangerous but that's why
having military to go and do this
otherwise you you could send EasyJet in
it strikes me that over over the weekend
we have taken quite a risk-averse
approach we we have thought it's a very
high risk situation so we put a security
heavy operation in 1200 people military
people
um Ben Wallace said to get 30 diplomats
out it seems that our European allies
went the other way and put security
light but airlift heavy in and used a
couple of hundred people probably to get
you know a thousand Europeans out so the
situation holds and we could repeat that
then as you've just heard we could put
on extra airlifts there will be there
will be some risk
um then the other options are some of
the other nations have done which is
either advise your Nationals to get to
some other hubs and then we'll pick them
up from there that could make the
airlift less risky or get to Ports do
down as many other nations have done and
then a ship across the Red Sea and
probably to Saudi and Jeddah but getting
to the collection points that you
suggest may be needed there clearly
involves some risk to these British
Nationals yes it does nothing's perfect
it never is on on these operations and
you've just heard at the moment doesn't
seem to an appetite to put you know
boots on the ground that would Stoke up
that would Stoke up a fight having said
that the United Nations has just
announced it's got hundreds of its
people out you know the Nigerians are
looking at getting 3 000 Nigerians out
probably across you know across the
border and it might be just low-key let
people find their own way get to a place
of safety and then you know we could
escort them from there there won't be a
perfect answer yeah other organizations
have got lots of people out why is it
taking
so long in the case of
um the British authorities well I
suspect that's because we took took the
view and I I don't know but I from the
announcements that this would be high
risk and along with the Americans who
explicitly stated they would not be
getting their people out we saw this as
a one-off mission to rescue the
government's personality in in theater
and that would be it now of course we're
faced with the fact that some of the
other nations European nations have got
many more of their citizens out and
we're going to have to come up with Plan
B okay Ed thank you very much indeed